[Music]
on today's show we're going to be
talking about anxiety depression
dealing with old grief how to talk to
your kids and take care of yourself
we're going to be talking about open
marriage and a disagreement of values
between a dad
and a son and the pain when the sun
decides to walk away
stay tuned
hey what's up i am john and this is the
dr
john dolone show where i'm taking your
calls about your life
about the challenges going on in your
homes and your hearts and your heads and
your families
we're talking about relationships
relational iq parenting
homeschooling mental health we're going
to talk about
parents who when their kid comes home
from school
and they say i would have got an a but
my teacher failed me because they hate
me
their parents they don't race up to the
school to start world war three
they pause and they think hmm my kid's
seven
or 12 or 17 or 22
maybe they had something to do with
their failure and not the professional
licensed teacher who probably loves kids
makes less money than they're worth
and works 24 7 365 because they just
want to help the next generation
maybe it was my kid so parents like you
i salute you
and maybe we'll talk about you today
here's the deal we talk about anything
and everything on the show so whatever's
going on in your heart
in your mind in your home i'm here to
walk with you
give me a call 1-844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
and again don't forget to email me at
ask ramseysolutions.com
that's askjohn ramseysolutions.com
we've got a whole full board of calls
here dude so let's go right to the calls
let's go with
jane in saint joe missouri jane how are
you this morning
i'm great thanks for taking my call
thank you so much for joining our show
here
hey i'm doing awesome awesome how can i
help
yeah so i'm just really struggling i'm a
single mom
and i'm struggling with trying to find
balance with everything that's going on
right now
obviously the pandemic and all of that
but i have sole custody of my
young child second grader she's in a
very intensive school program
i'm also in an intensive master's
program
and i'm just really struggling with
trying to find the balance of
hiring a babysitter and when i should
hire a babysitter and budgeting for that
and that it's okay to spend the money on
that versus
everything else and just trying to
figure out how to
handle all of that so let's back up a
little bit what are you getting a
master's degree in
mba and finance ooh very cool so you're
you're a smart person
you're absolutely the smartest person on
this phone call
all right so how long have you been
single how long have you been working
through this and figuring it out
um i've dated off and on for the last
six years but really nothing more than
about
nine i mean there was one that was nine
or ten months that was pretty serious
um but that was two years ago and how
old's your little one
uh seven boy or girl a little girl
tell me about her she's amazing she's
so she surprises me every day with just
the responsibility that she wants and
how helpful she is and she's so kind and
loving and caring and she just always
wants to be with mom she wants to
snuggle with mom
she wants to hang out she wants to
cuddle
and it's just she's great very cool so
when you
talk about getting a babysitter tell me
about that are you talking about you
want to go out
and you're struggling with that balance
of
are you allowed to go out because you're
a single mom and every second
every spare second not at work or school
should be going to your kids
you got that kind of guilt or you're
worried about
dating like what what are you worried
about with yeah i think
it's just everything i mean her father's
not really in the picture
he maybe picks her up hours so a week if
that someone
doesn't see her at all so i just
struggle with like
she wants to always be with mom and mom
is
so overly burnt out with everything
right now that i just
i feel bad telling her no like hey mommy
really needs to do this i really need to
and sometimes she's okay if we hire
babies if i hire a babysitter sometimes
she's not she's like why did you have to
do that
so then i feel worse because she's upset
because i left for a couple hours
sure so let's let's get a couple of
things into our hearts and minds okay
number one balance is a myth
it's not real and it doesn't exist
okay and so working full-time do you
work full-time
i do yeah what's your day job i'm a
project accountant
oh so you're just an all-around gangster
okay so you're a project accountant
full-time
you're going through an mba program
which is challenging
um it's not like some of my programs
where we
we thought through things yours has like
numbers right yours has facts and
figures that you've got to get right
um and you're also
have your number one priority which is
which is raising a child right
growing another human being modeling
what
what a good mom looks like what a strong
powerful brilliant
accomplished woman looks like you're
you've got a lot on your plate
this idea of balance is a myth okay so
what i want you to think through
and think about is when
winter or let me back up when summer
transitions to winter
we don't say that summer's broken
right we don't say that spring fell
apart
and then winter showed up it's just a
part of the seasons
right it's just the natural flow so
right now you're in a busy season
you're in winter and it's just cold and
what that means is you gotta
prep for it you're not gonna have as
many front doors um
sitting around in shorts and t-shirts
and flip-flops it's gonna have to be
coats and blankets right
and so it just means you have to plan
for it that's number one so balance is a
myth
you're in a messy season you're in a
busy season it's gonna pass
but you're in it and just acknowledge it
it's winter it's cold it is what it is
the third thing is this you have to put
your oxygen mask on first
before you're going to be any use to
your daughter
you've got to be well and what a lot of
parents do particularly
single parents is they start chasing out
of guilt out of frustration
out of i want to make sure that i can
fill
both of these parent roles all these
parent roles complete these circles
is they just start running around and
the kids end up driving and
to put your heart and mind at ease let
me tell you
that's going to bury your kid
it's a lot of pressure to put on a kid
to run a household
it's a lot of pressure to put on a kid
to make sure mom's okay to make sure i'm
always okay to make sure i'm always in
contact with mom
and so your job is to make sure you're
well make sure your boundaries are firm
and strong teach your daughter how to be
by herself teach your daughter how to
self soothe teach your daughter how to
be in relationship with great
babysitters and great support staff
great support help and also talk to your
daughter about seasons
mommy's in school right now it's not
always going to be this way but it's
busy right now and so we work
together as a team and once you can
get out of the balance myth once you can
get out of the you're failing your kid
by taking care of your needs
by getting a break by going to hang out
with friends by going to laugh
and be in community you've got to have
that stuff because otherwise your
daughter's just going to watch you with
her on the vine
she's a young kid she's going to absorb
a lot of that and she's going to assume
responsibility for some of that
and that's going to be a bad dance
between you and her for the rest of
y'all's time together
right so if you had to if you had to
just back out and say what do you really
need every week what would that what
would that be what would that look like
i think i just need to make a more
conscious
effort of putting the boundary in place
like no we can't go do that right now
mommy needs to go
meet with this friend and you just need
to hang out with the babysitter for an
hour or two and i'll be back and then we
can go do something different
okay jane you just did something really
important and i want you to flip this on
its head okay
i don't want your daughter to be
surprised what she's desperate for right
now is boundaries and control and
predictability
and so i want you to teach her sunday
night is
mommy and daughter night monday morning
is mommy and daughter night and this is
when we go through what the week is
going to look like
this is remember wednesday night is when
mommy goes out with mommy's friends
remember that friday nights is when
mommy goes and spends time with
mommy's friends saturday night is when
we have our
gopher hikes time right that way it's
not this response that way she's not
caught off guard that way she can begin
to build predictability into her week
and she gets to watch a strong
brilliant powerful mom trying to get
through every day she gets to watch her
model intentionality model planning
model model
how to manage relationships well and
healthy and whole starting with
taking care of her putting on her oxygen
mask first
and that's you and a nose is hard
just hear me say this i say it all the
time on this show
jane but you are worth time away
you're worth a good night sleep you're
worth having friends and
laughing and your daughter has to have
that she has to have a mom
who's got relationships outside of this
dynamic duo here
the seasons will pass summer will come
spring shows back up
you'll graduate from that nba you'll get
that other job that will give you some
space it'll give you some financial
space
it'll give you some space with your
daughter
it's gonna be good but this month it's
cold you're in winter this season is
cold
thank you so much for that call jane
what a saint all right let's go
from missouri over to
kendra in arkansas kendra good morning
how we doing
hey dr john thank you so much for taking
my ball
thank you for calling how can i help my
daughter is currently a senior in high
school
and she's already selected the college
she wants to go to but she's
very apprehensive about making that
transition
and she was diagnosed with anxiety and
depression in the past
and i just want to know how i can help
her with the transition
and let her know that it's going to be
okay
how are you doing with the transition
it's hard
i was going to say you don't sound like
you're doing well with it she's my baby
but
i'm also really excited for her to start
this next chapter
so i i look at anxiety as just an alarm
it's just a
something that tells us we're
disconnected our relationships
aren't whole right now there's something
fractured in those or i'm not
safe i'm out of control why are her
alarms going off
as a young kid why have they been going
off
um i think it's just a big change for
her she doesn't she's not comfortable
with change
no no no she you told me she's already
been diagnosed so what in her childhood
has has set those alarms off as she's
grown up
um well we we had a family loss
tell me about it um her cousin was
killed in a car wreck
about five years ago hmm were they close
like siblings yes i'm sorry
she work through that and process that
um i think it was really hard for her to
she was only 12 at the time and i think
it was really hard for her to see
her the people in her life
fall apart um we've
we've always been a close-knit family
and she's never really had to experience
grief before that and
i think you know seeing the people that
are supposed to be strong and protect
her
fall apart just i
i don't think she knew how to handle
that gotcha
and that loss still seems really fresh
in your heart
it is so here's
a couple of things i want you to think
through trauma
and grief have no clock
they've got no calendar and
those alarms that i'm not safe that any
day i can die in a car wreck
that any day somebody i love and care
for and rely on can just be ripped out
of my life and gone forever
those alarms will spin and spin and spin
particularly in the hearts and minds of
a child
and i know for adults they feel like
when they fall apart
after grief when they are grieving when
they're hurting and crying
and hard to console they think that that
damages kids
it actually humanizes adults it gives
kids a window
into the idea that their parents have
feelings that they're real people
they're not robots
and so it may feel untethering at the
time but it actually can be a gift over
time
especially if you know the funeral was
good
there is a a constant conversation
death is normed we we grieve the loss
and then we go make meaning on the back
end of it
and so what i would i want you to back
out
and think less about how's my daughter
going to make this transition moving
forward
i would love for you to honor your
daughter honor the memory of this cousin
by taking your daughter out she's a
senior right now right so she's working
through her last year of high school
yes what would be a really holy
wonderful and it's going to be hard and
tear-filled
i'd love you all to have a regular
weekly breakfast have a
regular weekly walk together and just
say i'm your mom
you're i'm going to make you do this
you're a senior and i don't even care
what you think is cool or not cool
and we're going to spend some time
together and i want you to start
like remember back when we lost cousin
like i want to tell you how i
experienced that
how much that still hurts me and i want
you to give your daughter permission and
space to feel
permission and space to talk i want you
to teach her about writing a letter to
your
cousin like hey i've missed you the last
five years i'm good ready to go to
college
here's who i'm gonna be and you can give
your daughter a
really extraordinary gift and that is
modeling what grieving looks like what
honoring
and understanding and experiencing loss
looks like
and if if that sets off a series of
other
alarms in her life which it might then
make sure she's connected to a good
counselor as she transitions out she's
gonna need to learn some skills on how
to turn the anxiety alarms off
because here's the thing anxiety is
about disconnection
lack of control are you safe when you
pluck a kid out of everything they know
and you plug them into some strange
ecosystem somewhere
and say go get them then those those
three things pop
up right i don't know anybody here i
don't know if i'm safe here
and i'm completely disconnected
unpredict life is unpredictable
and so the alarms are naturally going to
go off here's an interest well i won't
go down that road that's a whole other
conversation
so how does that sound when i say that
to you it
sounds spot on okay
are you willing to do that for her oh
absolutely
okay are you willing to do that for
yourself
yes because my guess is you experience
anxiety too
yes and my guess is when
you experience depression too and here's
all depression is just think of it
as holding your hands and just taking
your feelings and shoving them down
like too depressed like you take a
popsicle stick and depress your tongue
down they call it a tongue depressor
same thing and the more those alarms
ring and the more we put pillows over
the alarms instead of dealing with
the house that's on fire the more and
more we quote unquote depress
the more our body tries to numb us out
and and do away with those alarms just
so we can get through the day and get
through the day and get through the day
losing a young kid can take your heart
and soul from you
you gotta have people that walk along
with you and you gotta at some point
turn and face that storm intentionally
it's
hard it's hard it's heartbreaking
but you can't find meaning on the other
side
and wow parents if you can give the gift
of teaching your kids
modeling for your kids how to grieve how
to acknowledge loss
how to cry in front of your kids
how to write letters to loved ones that
have passed
when those alarms go off that say you're
not safe you're not safe how to teach
your kid how to go
i am right now i'm okay right now i'm
safe
oh my gosh you're talking legacy change
you're talking generational change
and the cousin's not going to be
forgotten the cousin's going to be
honored
the cousins who passed away as a young
kid
there's going to be meaning that blooms
out of that would we do anything to give
the cousin back
you're dang right we would we trade it
all to have her back but she's gone
and so how do we make meaning on the
back end of that
i recommend anybody who's experienced
loss who's dealing with the anxiety
alarms stemming from
undealt with grief david kessler's book
finding meaning
came out in 2019 it's maybe the best
grief book i've ever read
i read it straight through and started
it right over it's extraordinary
remarkable david kessler we'll put a
link to it in the show notes
it's world class if you're struggling
with grief if you're struggling with
anxiety
out stemming from grief please check
that book out thank you so much for that
call kendra
wow what a gift all right let's go to
william in lexington kentucky
william how we doing brother i'm doing
fine and you dr john
man i'm getting it you just made my
hearts of my heart sing a little bit man
how long have you been in kentucky uh
since 92 that's right outstanding well
brother how can i help you this morning
well i recently found out and um
i'm really upset about this i recently
found out that my
uh 30 middle 30 year old son
is in an open marriage okay
how'd you find out well one night we
were sitting there
he was in my home and we were talking
and uh he shared that with my wife and i
and justin was it just as an
off-site just hey what's your favorite
movies oh by the way guys i'm
in an open marriage i mean or did he sit
down and say hey i need to talk to you
all about something
no no it just popped up like uh just a
little bit of trivia
wow the next morning
after i had you know essentially settled
down a little bit
um i told him that
that i will always love him but i will
never approve of an open marriage
and so that went on for maybe a month
and then i went up to his home and he
and i sat down and spoke
and i prefaced my talk with you know i
will always love you you will always be
my son
i will respect your wife because you
chose her
but i will never approve of your open
marriage
and he admitted to it that he's in an
open marriage
and apparently he's been in an open
marriage since they've been married for
three years
and to make a long story short he
essentially what he said was
i will go with people that still love me
no matter what i do and so essentially
he canceled me out
so my question to you is where do i go
from here
where do you want to go man well
i will never approve of an open marriage
right um my judeo-christian beliefs will
not allow me to do that there's just no
way in the world
hey brother i'm telling you common sense
tells me it's not a good idea right
no like i'm a christian guy too i share
your values there but there's just
common sense right
so well i i i shared with him that there
was a
90 92 percent chance of they will get a
divorce
they will always have trusted trust
issues
if they they do not have any children
but if they have children then who's
going to be the father
you know all those things we we spoke
with all those things
so let's let's back out a little bit
this is a hard question i'm going to ask
you okay
okay did he come to you to ask for your
approval
yes and so he when he sat down with you
he said dad i want your blessing on this
well essentially before we met the last
time he sent me various articles
in support of an open marriage oh good
god so he's trying to uh
convert you yeah okay
so he sought your opinion you gave it to
him he didn't like what
you had to say and he said we'll fool
you on you
correct okay and so when he says i'm i'm
canceling you out old man
does that mean he doesn't want you to
come around does that mean he says i'm
never coming to your house
you and mama's house again what does
that mean
yes he doesn't want to come to the house
he doesn't want to be around us
because in his last text to me
he said that he has christian friends
that support what they do and that's who
he will
reciprocate his love to okay
had that text hit you
well i would like to meet the christian
friends i would too man
i would too but but
put those friends aside put those
thoughts and ideas aside how did that
hit you
i didn't like it but i'm not going to
sell out to the devil
to to gain uh the favor of my son
okay so where you find yourself is is
this
you've got some principles and values
that you're standing firm on
you made a commitment and values
and stances often come at a cost
and i don't know that there's a greater
cost than losing connection with your
son
and i don't think you lost that
connection i think your son asked you
for your
thoughts and opinions you gave them and
then he made a decision to walk away
and as a parent of a child
you're a parent i mean you're not a
parent of a child you're a parent of a
grown man
he's 30 you say he's 36
yeah he's he's he's 36 he's almost 40
years old
he's making a decision to walk away
based on he's throwing a grown-up temper
tantrum saying i don't want to be around
my daddy because i have just
different opinions in him and he's he's
just
selecting to walk him walk out
and that leaves you two options go
running after him
and say honey honey honey or to say my
door is always open for you my car door
is always open i will get in and come
visit you i'll come hang out i will love
you
but if he chooses to walk away from you
he chooses to walk away from you yeah
and that's heartbreaking and that stinks
i mean you're in an either or choice
right now
actually you're not man i'm thinking
this as out loud as i'm talking
he's making the call dude yes
and it's his decision to make that's
right so here's what you need to do
you need to this and this is probably
not a popular thing
for older gentlemen in um kentucky
all right and i just made a gross
generalization and all the people from
kentucky can send me
me mean cards and letters i understand
but listen
you are going to have to grieve the
separation of your son
because where this is really quickly
going to turn in your heart and mind if
you don't deal with it it's going to
turn into bitterness
it's going to turn into anger and it's
going to be like that old a.a saying
which is you're going to be poisoning
yourself hoping somebody else dies
correct you're going to have to grieve
the fact that your son
and you have different opinions on open
marriages or closed marriages
and that he chose to walk away from you
because he didn't appreciate what you
had to say
he is choosing friends over dad
yes at this time that's correct
i want you to hear me though will that
that hurts and that stinks
and i'm sorry
yes it does hurt but um
you are but but behind that principle
behind that principle is a daddy
yeah and i don't want you to miss that
because behind principle and behind
values
are people and sometimes we stand really
strong on principles we stand really
strong on values
and we ignore that dad that remembers
playing catch with his boy
and you gotta honor that guy too it's
okay to have principles and values and
it's okay to be sad
those aren't incompatible okay and what
i'm telling you is if you don't honor
the sadness
if you don't honor the grief that your
son chose to bail on you for a season
and i think you're right he's gonna come
back he knows his old man loves him
i think he's gonna circle back but if
you don't grieve that it will turn to
bitterness and it will
crush you okay well
i've shared it with my with my sisters
and
uh it's it's not something that i have
kept to myself
right because historically i have found
when i
when i tend to internalize things like
not like that but internalize things
that
stress me or cause me stress then it
becomes worse
and so from the point from the from the
get-go
i shared with my my sisters and they
felt
you know they it just felt good to get
it out
yes sir good good stay in contact with
them and don't be afraid to
not rally people around to your support
you
but don't be afraid even if you got to
text him it's not the best way to do it
but even if you got to text him
text your sisters text a friend an old
buddy
and just say i miss my son today and i'm
sad
i'm going to be all right but today i
just woke up and i miss my son
i'm sad and
to all of the dads and the sons and the
moms and the daughters out there
man be careful about cancelling
relationships even if you disagree
even if you all have core virtue issues
man love your parents
even if they think differently than you
even if they try to give you wisdom
i know when you're 20 and 30 you think
you know everything and i figured out
this new solution to this and this and i
want to go run
feel good over here and man
i'm telling you even if they don't know
how to say it right your moms and dads
love you
i have yet to see the data that open
marriage solves anything
i haven't seen it i don't think it's a
good idea i think it's a terrible idea
i wish people would sit down and have
deeper harder conversations with their
spouses
about what they want what they need from
one another that's a whole other
different conversation
and that's what this call presented as
that's not what this call was about this
is called
about a dad who's got some firm
principles who was honest with his son
son came to him and said hey dad what do
you think about this and his dad said
i think that's not a wise decision son i
don't i don't think that's wise at all
i think you're going to end up hurt i
think you're going to end up in a mess
and i love you and i don't want you to
be in a mess and i don't want to see you
hurt
and his son threw a temper tantrum took
his ball and went home
and said fine daddy i've got other
friends who who are different than you
they'll let me just do whatever i want
and they'll high-five me and say
you do you you go you you take care of
you
man those aren't friends man those
aren't friends
hmm
all right i'm gonna take a breath
william thanks for that call brother
all right let's transition over let's
take one more call let's go over to
jennifer in raleigh north carolina
jennifer how are you this morning
i'm doing well i hope you are thank you
for taking my call hey thank you so much
for calling in how can i help
so about well most of my life i've had
some
mental health issues and about five
years ago
i went and sought help and got on
medication
and it seems to be working pretty well
um but my question is
ever since i was younger my i've kind of
gotten an impression from my parents
that they don't necessarily believe in
medications that it's more
of a mindset and i'm trying to figure
out a way to
open those communications with them and
let them know what's going on with me
and on the flip side i have a 15 year
old daughter that i would like to
open those lines of communications up
with as well
oh that's awesome that's some good stuff
here okay so number one why do you feel
like you need to tell your parents
what's going on
well honestly i think my mom might have
some issues that she could
talk to somebody benefit from talking to
somebody about but
truthfully i am a single mom and my mom
and dad
are my emergency contacts okay
and if something was to go wrong you
know they need medical issues and things
like that i don't want them to ever be
surprised if something comes up
do you think something's going to come
up no no
but at the same time you know it's just
one of those things that i would like
for us to have the open communication so
then
i don't know i i kind of i guess i want
my parents approvals
on things like this ding ding ding ding
so here's the deal
there's a fantasy with that one that
you're gonna have to let go
okay and the sooner you can put that one
down
and let it just flutter off like a
butterfly my guess is
that will be one of the first steps
towards you
having healing in your heart and mind
okay you're not going to get their
approval on this one
is my guess gotcha
if they are and i know folks like this
they've got good hearts i don't think
they're evil
they just think mental health is a crock
they think
that um anybody taking them galdurn
pills
is just a knucklehead or weak or a wimp
or whatever
right and they're you're just not gonna
change their mind
you're gonna they're gonna get defensive
you're gonna get defensive you're gonna
feel hurt you're not gonna get the
approval that you were seeking and it's
just gonna
it's gonna be three steps back for your
own wellness and so the biggest gift you
can give yourself
is to take them out of your box and what
i mean by that is you should have a box
of people
three or four of them at the most maybe
five if you're if you're crazy
and they're the ones who get to speak
into your life
and i do have that i do have friends
that you know i i do share that with
and things like that i just i guess i
also want to be able to open it up with
my daughter and if my daughter brings it
up to my parents
because they have a pretty open
relationship as well sure so
this is that's a whole other
conversation i 1000
think you should sit down with your
daughter and be honest and open
okay i think that's a wonderful gift
that a mother can pass along to her
daughter
this idea especially a single mom here's
some of the challenges i've gone through
here's some of the things i'm doing to
take care of myself to put my oxygen
mask on first
how to take care of myself so that i'm
whole so i can take care of you and love
you the way you deserve to be loved
but more importantly to model it you can
tell her everything you want but after
you all have a series of conversations
you teach her about what's going on in
your heart and head
um then she's going to watch it closely
and she's going to learn from you what a
strong
brilliant powerful awesome woman
does when she's struggling right
and they don't go to war with people who
they're not gonna
it's just gonna be futile right they
don't try to convince people that don't
wanna be convinced
they don't invite themselves into
conversations that they know is gonna
end painful and painfully um and so
yeah i would let your mom and dad go
don't cancel relationships with them
like they were just talking no no no we
have
a great relationship um they're great
parents and everything like that i've
just always gotten the impression that
they don't think the way i do
on this topic sure and so i think a key
for you is to make peace with it in your
heart
and then if it comes up naturally
because i i i'm getting from your call
you don't feel
super sold on it and when we don't feel
super
sold we feel we feel like we go tell
other people in our lives and we rally
them around to our way of seeing things
and it helps us feel better about what
we're doing and so
if you're finding peace and you're
finding wellness
and you're working with a counselor or a
physician towards
taking care of yourself then go with
that
trust the professionals there and go
with it and if it comes up naturally in
conversation you can be like oh yeah mom
i've been in counseling for a while
i went through a divorce just kind of
nailed it on the head with the whole
getting peace with myself about it i
i never thought of it that way yeah you
have lingering
you're carrying some of their baggage
with you right
so can i just can we can i ask you
something i tend to think
anxiety depression those those are just
signals they're alarm systems
right that tell me one of three things
i'm disconnected my relationships are
busted
i am um
not safe something in my ecosystem is
telling me i'm not safe and it may be
childhood traumas that are rear in their
heads
or i'm out of control i'm in a situation
where i can't control anything
and i don't i don't feel like it's going
to end well why are your
alarms going off probably the latter
the out of control and needing to get
more control
when did you start spinning out honestly
when i was i remember being really young
and thinking about reaching out to
psychiatrists and things like that back
when i was a teenager did you grow up in
a chaotic situation
no no my parents were great my
everything was great
um maybe i kind of felt
that i was luckier than most people
but with things like that but no no
nothing that i can recall at all that's
a that's fantastic and so you find
yourself
a single mom working through it i think
you are
um i mean you're you're being brave
you've got to trust your counselor
you've got to trust your doctor
and then you've got to have an open
dialogue with your daughter
have an open dialogue with a daughter be
a great teacher be a mom
not a friend you're her mom but be a
great teacher be a great
modeler and then just love your parents
for who they are
they're going to have their thoughts on
things if they invite you into a
conversation be honest of course
if they say hey what is all this about
this counseling stuff we hear about on
the internet
every once in a while you can say
mom i've been in counseling for a while
and it's it's extraordinary
or if they make if they say what do you
think about this medication i think it's
nonsense
you can say anxiety medication helps
turn the alarms down a little bit
it helps turn the alarms down a little
bit so that i can
actually do the hard work of getting
well i'm not going to be on them forever
but they really do help turn that
sharpness down just so i can actually
hear a counselor i can start hearing
relationships i can start trusting
myself again
i can connect fully with my daughter
because i don't have both hands over my
ears trying to protect myself from these
alarms
man you're talking about legacy change
there you're talking about
really changing the way your daughter
grows up jennifer the way she sees her
mom the way she sees herself
the way she's going to see her daughters
that's a brave brave move
vulnerability requires courage and
bravery
and it's the right thing to do good for
you jennifer good for you
you're a good mom love your parents for
where they are
and be about changing your daughter's
tomorrow invest in her teach her about
you and you're going to change your
hearts and mind good for you
all right so as we wrap up today's show
i want to go to
the greatest song of all time it's a
song that i remember hearing for the
first time
i was on my front porch i had a little
boy
i was worried about my students i was
worried about the direction of
the country i was worried about my son
i was worried about what kind of dad i
was gonna be
and i stumbled onto this song off
andrew peterson's 2012 record light for
lost boy
and he wrote this song for one of his
sons and it's called you'll find your
way and i remember hearing this song
doubling over on my front porch
weeping and raising my head
wiping the tears away and understanding
that the world spins and it moves on
and our kids are more resilient than we
think they are our hearts are more
resilient than we think they are
people are mostly good doing the best
they can with the tools they've got
i appreciate andy writing the song it's
called you'll find your way he writes
when i look at you boy i can see the
road that lies ahead
i can see the love and the sorrow bright
fields of joy
dark nights awake in a stormy bed i want
to go with you
but i can't follow your first kiss
your first crush the first time you know
you're not enough
the first time there's no one there to
hold you the first time you pack it all
up and drive alone across america please
remember
the words that i told you keep to the
old roads
i know you'll be scared and i know it'll
hurt
but keep to the old roads and you'll
find your way
this is the dr john deloney show